ahora vamos a limpiar la pantalla para
hablar sobre la forma de la función ce
no vamos a hacerlo
esta es una gráfica de la función seno
donde el ángulo theta va a estar en este
eje horizontal
hemos puesto a theta como una línea
recta en lugar de estar dando vueltas en
este círculo si dibujamos una línea acá
este es un círculo unitario por lo que
su radio es de 1 si dibujamos esta línea
aquí y este es un círculo unitario la
definición de seno de teta aquí está
theta es el opuesto entre la hipotenusa
este es el lado opuesto y este lado
opuesto del triángulo tiene un valor de
g
por lo que el seno de teta es igual hay
entre la hipotenusa pero nuestra
hipotenusa es igual a 1 y va a ser así
en todos los casos si gráfico esto en la
curva éste es un ángulo y voy por acá
hasta llegar a este punto y lo graficó
así y conforme theta gira alrededor del
círculo
graficar los diferentes valores de y si
llega aquí a este valor de aquí abajo
pueden ver que esto se grafica aquí
cuando el ángulo regresa de nuevo a cero
la función de seno también va a regresar
a cero y se repite nuevamente conforme
nuestro ángulo gira así que el signo de
dos pies cero igual que el seno de cero
y cada dos pin
aquí me salgo de la pantalla pero voy a
tener que mi función seno va a ser igual
a cero ahora haremos lo mismo con la
función coseno ahora graphic haremos la
proyección de este valor en esta gráfica
coseno de aquí abajo
esta función coseno tiene el eje de
tiempo que va hacia abajo y nuestra
definición de coseno es el lado
adyacente entre la hipotenusa en nuestro
dibujo la hipotenusa vale 1
el coseno de teta es igual al adyacente
y en este caso el adyacente es igual al
valor que tiene en el eje x dividido
entre la hipotenusa que vale 1 en este
diagrama el coseno de teta es el valor
en x que es esta equis de acá vamos a
quitar esto un momento y comencemos
desde el principio con el radio sobre el
eje horizontal positivo y sabemos que el
coche no detecta cuando theta es igual a
0 va a ser igual a 1 así que si hago mi
proyección aquí abajo de este ángulo 0
lo voy a tener en este punto de aquí
ahora continuamos vamos con un ángulo
más grande esta proyección ahora va a
llegar aquí sobre la curva cuando la
flecha está directamente hacia arriba
estaremos en este punto de aquí
regresamos al eje si continuamos esto se
va a proyectar aquí
y ahora aquí recuerden que estamos
moviendo nuestro vector radio hacia acá
este va a tener el mismo valor que antes
pero va a estar graficado en esta parte
de la curva ahora y cuando regresemos a
cero de nuevo la proyección va a estar
en este punto de acá esta es una forma
de visualizar cómo se genera la curva
coseno por un vector que está rotando
alrededor de un círculo el coche no va
hacia abajo porque es una proyección del
eje horizontal y cuando hicimos el seno
fue una proyección del eje vertical me
gusta visualizar esto así porque este
vector que rota es una idea muy simple
pero muy poderosa y vemos que es una
forma de generar ondas seno y cosenos y
también vemos que de forma natural
tienen fases diferentes el seno inicia
en cero y el coseno comienza en uno y
con esta forma de dibujarlo nos damos
cuenta de por qué ocurre así así que
esta relación entre círculos y vectores
que rotan o giran y se
y cosenos es una idea muy poderosa de la
que vamos a hacer uso en nuestros vídeos